[Music]
gary lynn
or daryl lynn what what is this one damn
i don't know daryl lynn
is in bend oregon hey daryl lynn how are
you
good having you i'm destroying your name
what is it
darylan daryl anne okay darling i'm so
sorry how can i help
no you're fine um i have a quick
question about
a truck loan we just got um my husband
went and bought a
truck for his business um and so my
question
is should we pay off the truck loan with
our personal finances because we have
um some savings we're looking at buying
a house eventually
um so we have a down payment savings in
the bank right now
and we could pay off the truck in full
but it wouldn't be the business account
paying off the truck right now it would
be the
personal savings account darwin it's a
personal loan he signed for it
personally
it's not a business yeah our business is
not very big
he just justified buying a truck that he
didn't need and
bought himself a dadgum truck did he
pretty brand new one yeah yeah he went
but he went and bought him a boy toy and
he's called it business
i'm calling bs yeah just pay it off it
was a stupid idea and you can't justify
it and call it business because it's not
a business loan bank didn't make the
business alone the bank made you a loan
it's personal you're personally liable
on this
yeah we'll use it for the business
because he has a guiding business for
hunting
and so he had to get a truck for that
but um yeah so how much does he make in
his guiding business
around 80 000 this year okay and what'd
the truck cost
35. yeah see i told you it's bs didn't i
there's no way you take an 80 000 gross
revenue business and do a 35
dollar investment that you could have
done for five thousand and
he a five thousand dollar truck will do
a guiding business
so the other thirty that he spent was
because he wanted a truck
that's what this was and this is a
classic small business mistake
by the way everybody does it but yeah
you guys got
my point is i'm not going to make a big
deal about this one but you guys got to
stop that crap because it's going to
make you it's an excuse to continue to
do stupid
and you can't do it so you shouldn't
have bought it bad idea
can't business justify it that's just
that's just not the truth okay so anyway
pay it off
and uh don't do this kind of stuff again
do not
do this kind of stuff again